welcome to this video yeah this blitz
game and you notice something is
different yes I've edit the coordinates
um yes I always felt a bit reluctant to
do that because it eats up some screen
state and yeah well they never found the
layout that aligned but this I actually
do like so I welcome feedback on that if
you like it or whatever it's some
something that I want to try out okay um
while I was talking I have fun entered
this line of them of the tirage which I
actually didn't know it don't know well
I normally play D takes five instead of
pushing g5 but while talking I
completely forgot that I think taking
and b3 is how it goes but I have
basically forgotten forgotten though the
theory here not sure I think Queen 85
something like that is right but yeah
something like that why am black
normally tries to to use them to use the
somewhat unstable position of the night
I wonder if I should just drop back to
detune it's probably not the critical
news ok madam creates a an immediate
threat did you close the door
yeah the dishwasher was so loud that it
probably made it to the sound of the
video okay let's see not quite sure
black is black doing here maybe yeah
what we should before as a possibility
but after move like Quincy to em I have
a three year and on the on the horizon
and this is not sure that this is so
great maybe you should move the Queen
again to be six or something okay he
went for that it's certainly the most um
I'm the most principled moving away okay
I need to cover c3 in quincy to as the
most obvious way to do it I'm not sure
though I mean what I want to do is I
want to play threaten a three and if I
go Quincy to maybe on a three can take
on b3 then hmm maybe ok I'll Quincy one
wasn't alternative but ok he's reacting
to that by taking so i can take now with
the pawn this looks looks quite
comfortable for me I think I can play
night a four is this some technically a
good move or not you will take on d4 of
course but I have night a form anyway
even if I even if a player moves like
III I can play night a for just the next
move night a for Queen D for Bishop
before Queen before Quincy success not
bad but are not so not so convincing I
can light a four and this looks like a
a good position I think you must react
in a way to that you cannot allow allow
me to trade the dark squared bishop for
example I think you should probably
retreat it Wow madis I didn't even
consider giving giving me the bishop a
on top of all the problems that he
already has okay Bishop a five and then
before or before immediately or work a
five is also also pretty good move maybe
you can drive there are many of good
good possibilities tending rook fa 1
we're keeping keeping the tension you
know before was also possible what's the
simplest maybe just blocking both 85 and
c5 here you can maybe play c5
theoretically speaking at least you can
do that thing that I don't think it did
blunders material or something like that
but I can take twice black queen bee to
for example and just have a very nice
position with two bishops well c 5 is
probably probably just bad actually okay
it's very typical I just say okay this
is just bad and then then it's played
okay so queen bee Torah or is there a
better move no no 32 of course yeah of
course yeah just a mouse clip of course
after Queen B 2 I guess reason like ass
black is almost busted him do this
strategically losing position almost
let's check what is the comp doing plus
2 yeah that's no surprise to two bishops
open board a7 is
g7 is weak he decided never moved here
really we should have six what's blacks
move here can can retreat if you like
rugae one Bishop to g4 I will probably
win the a porn this is just a complete
disaster see if ya will see 5 is just
out of this world terrible I mean how
can you play that maybe if you expect
the other guy to make a more sleep than
you can yeah what a black should do is
probably something like this then the
question is how to continue before is a
move just blocking this I mean this is a
long-term long-term edge anyway it's
just a matter of home what continuation
to choose I could also it can even take
on e4 that's something to consider
because simply for concrete reasons here
so here Luke see one I get here and i
have this d5 possibility with a good
structure I mean it's it's not it I
wouldn't have played it but it's a it's
a possibility and yet the whole sequence
of museum is just not good for black I
actually even doubt Bishop before be
sure before already looks wrong to me it
just runs into this a three idea and
this is just bad I've been here this 94
now you absolutely must retreat the
bishop in my book or not the Queen you
cannot cannot do what this is unplayable
almost and c5 is probably losing yeah
unless you play quidditch oh yeah this
is the type of game where sometimes
don't upload stuff like that happens on
both sides actually but ok it was
probably interesting anyway from a
strategical point of view I think here
like already should play something else
maybe Queen a6l could be an idea
something like that the problem is what
he's doing here is he in a way um helps
me to exchange those bishops and what
you absolutely don't want to exchange
dark squared bishop in this position as
the porn see on light squares probably
those two will trade at some point and
then I have a very nice post on c5 and
you want the dark squared bishop to to
fill those dark square holes so Bishop
before it's not a good move and well
this is just a serious of mistakes but
ok one very bad mouseland can turn it
turn upside down ok thanks for watching